I'm Danica Patrick and I'm pretty
intense we have people that have healed
themselves of stage 4 cancer not once
not twice not three times and four times
over and over again we have people have
healed themselves that were blind that
were deaf that had tumors that had
Graves disease hashimoto's syndromes
numerous Parkinson's patients brain
injuries MS rheumatoid arthritis is
where Jesus was doing back in the day I
mean like blindness and stuff if anybody
is surprised I tell you that yes me I
never thought I would see these kind of
changes now you have this you have
evidence right now in testimony so no
evidence becomes the loudest voice right
yeah so doctors now are saying hey
you're not really responding to
treatment I'm why don't you try this now
let me tell you why they're saying that
and that's because if you say try this
and you see the evidence of people
getting better and the person's not
responding to treatment what else do you
have and doctors are now referring
oncologists or referring patients right
to our office right to our of events
because it's an option for them so then
you have three types of stress physical
chemical and emotional stress is when
your brain and body are knocked out of
balance the stress response is what your
body innately does return it back to
order all organisms can tolerate
short-term stress but the chronic stress
is what pushes the genetic buttons that
create disease no most dress ends up as
emotional or psychological stress so
physical stress trauma accidents
injuries Falls chemical stress toxins
pesticides pollutants bacteria viruses
molds hangovers and then you have
emotional stress family tragedies second
mortgages single parenting 401 k's you
know traffic whatever and all of those
things knock the brain body out of
homeostasis but the emotional stress is
the challenge because the person can be
taking care of their body you know
eating all the right foods taking all
the drugs taking all the right vitamins
all the enzymes doing the things doing
yoga during the long-distance running
whatever it is that they're into but if
they're living in constant fear because
of some threat in their outer world is
either real or imagined or they're
theirs
mismanaging of their thoughts that those
thoughts keep producing the fear so
turning on that stress response by
thought alone then they could eat the
most organic healthy diet do all the
right exercise but the body's living in
survival because that stress so now
you're mobilizing all this energy for
some thread in your outer world and
there's no energy in your inner world
for growth and repair and so you your
body is actually utilizing all of its
vital resources when it's feeling fear
when it's feeling aggression or anger
when it's feeling pain and suffering
yeah the body is mobilizing enormous
amounts of resources if you're being
chased by a tiger you're not gonna use
20% of your resources
you're gonna go all-in right so then
what if it's not a tiger what if it's
just traffic so what was once highly
gaffney becomes very maladaptive and
when you turn on the stress response and
you can't turn it off now you're headed
for disease
you